so to give you the picture of how this
Data Platform puts together we're gonna
use a scenario of an advertising agency
that puts ads in the back of those
screens in New York City taxis if ever
if you've been in a cab recently New
York New York there's an ad that plays
and you can interact with it to give you
the picture first this is a simplified
architecture of this data solution the
taxis are sending their position in real
time where they are in the city as well
as their destination how many passengers
they have and what sort of interactions
the customers are doing pub/sub is then
ingesting that data we're using data
flow to process a data pipeline to
handle and process all that data
we're also archiving the entire
historical data in bigquery which is a
really powerful tool for you to do ad
hoc analysis of all of your historical
data and at the end we want to make a
visualization numb so why don't we
actually see the the pipeline in action
so this is the data flow visualization
tool and you see Roberts hovered we're
ingesting a little over 15,000 new
elements per second into this database
of all of this information but how do
you visualize all that Google Maps is
super powerful but I'd hate to point
fifteen thousand updates per second at
my Chrome browser so the map say so data
flow actually allows us to down sample
that event stream to give us a real-time
visualization of taxi positions and this
is that visualization this is showing
where all these taxis are in New York
City at any given time now what if I
want to look at one particular customer
who's who's placed ads with us a
particular agency we can filter that
data flow and now the visualization will
update so that we're only seeing ads
that are being placed for a specific
store in this case the Acme store it
looks like is on the Upper East Side and
sure enough we see that we're placing
ads roughly geographically near the
store but right now we're just using a
dumb rule for this it's just a very
simple rule where's the store where's
the taxi place the ads can we do better
can we automate this to start to take
into account all the various data that
we have about this well let's start by
using bigquery to sort of explore this
data set the query Robert has here he
looks at all of the taxis coming from
the airports and
to see how many of them are traveling
near restaurants now note here he's
querying this historical data even as
we're ingesting new data at 15,000
events per second so bigquery gives him
the ability to have an always up-to-date
real-time view into his into his data in
this case we see that roughly 17% of our
taxis are from the airport and near a
restaurant well that sounds like an
insight that maybe we ought to do some
some ad targeting there and if you look
at this query you can see it really is a
non-trivial query and bigquery is
handling all that for us so right now we
are manually configuring these ads so I
think what we want to do is look at a
way that we can do this in an automatic
fashion now we could similarly search
for every different customer but how do
we build a generalizable inflexible
model well that sounds like a job for
machine learning machine learning is
tailor-made for taking large chunks of
data and building models that give you
insights out of that so we're going to
build a model that intakes into account
all of the data we have
where'd the taxi start where did it end
how many people were in it what time of
day is it where's it going first we're
going to start by using as you see in
this picture we're gonna use data prep
to take all that historical data clean
it up make sure that it's ready to use
and then we're gonna use it with ml
engine so this is data prep the first
thing to notice is across the top data
prep has automatically inferred the
schema from my table I didn't have to
tell it that now if you look at that
passenger count column you'll notice
that it looks a little funny the
histogram up at the top includes some
elements where it's like this says
there's 10 or 11 people now I know about
you but I've been in a New York City
cabin I'm pretty sure you can't actually
put 10 or 11 people in a cab so that's a
common data bug data prep allows me to
fix that in a number of ways I could
delete the data I could replace that 11
with a one on the theory that it's a
fat-finger mistake and data prep allows
me to build simple recipes that clean up
my entire data at scale it also can do
things like if you look at our location
column there it's a composite column
it's longitude and latitude comma
separated I'd really like to have a
latitude column and a longitude column
prep allows me to build a recipe that
splits columns with composite data into
separate columns so that I now have a
better schema to work with now this just
scratches the surface of how data prep
can take this really tedious job of
preparing data for analytics and make it
much faster and much more reliable once
we've done this machine learning as you
heard from Faye Faye allows me to build
a model on my laptop upload it to Google
and deploy it at scale let's see how
that actually works if you scroll down
in the data flow pipeline you'll see
we've added an ml engine call so now as
our taxi data is coming in we're calling
to machine learning with the data and
saying help us choose the prep the best
ad to target for this particular user so
let's switch back over to the map with
the deployed machine learning model and
now you'll see that we start seeing some
interesting combinations when there's
one passenger coming in towards Midtown
the taxi is currently in in Chelsea and
it's on its way to Midtown
we're presenting an offer for Manhattan
bagels because it's a single person
maybe he or she wants a bite to eat if
we pick a taxi that has more than one
person in it if you have pet taxi with
more than one person in it there it is
in this case that's still not that's a
one person one but they're heading into
a different location and instead we've
chosen a winery if you pick a taxi with
three people the system would
automatically recommend discounted
tickets to Broadway for example as
multiple people coming to Midtown in the
evening so that's cloud ml making
suggestions based on all our available
data we used pub/sub to ingest a huge
stream of data at scale we use data flow
to build a pipeline to give us a good
analytics system we used bigquery so
that we always had the complete
historical data available we never had
to deal with sampled data and at the end
we use cloud ml and data prep to build
an Train at scale a model what's
important here's what you didn't see I
didn't deploy a virtual machine
I didn't deploy patches I spent my time
actually in the data that's the point of
big data is to spend the time in the
data not in the machines that take care
of the data
and that's what big data on the Google
platform does so I want to thank you all
and I'll turn it back over to Brian
[Applause]